plus de gendarmes dans les Yvelines le 2
octobre dernier le gouvernement annoncé
la création de deux nouvelles brigades
dans le département d'ici à 2027 une
réflexion menée depuis janvier 2022 et
les annonces du président de la
République en début d'année le ministre
de l'Intérieur géralde darmana
rencontrait des élus yvelinois sur la
commune d'ébrevvièr pour mieux cibler
les préoccupations le fruit de cette
concertation a été le le résultat de
deux constats le premier c'est une
augmentation sensible de la délinquence
sur le temps long au centre du
département le deuxième ça a été
également une augmentation de la
population en zone gendarmerie qui crée
pour demain et sur le temps long un
besoin de sécurité supplémentaire à Ben
une unité fixe verra le jour avec une
dizaine de gendarmes présents ils
s'installeront temporairement dans ce
local prêté par la commune avant une
implantation définitive la réaction
était de joie puisque cela fait
plusieurs mois qu'on était en relation
avec le groupement de gendarmerie pour
voir la possibilité je dis bien
possibilité d'installer une brigade de
gendarmerie sur ben tu vas pas être que
pour Ben bien évidemment mais
certainement pour les autres communes
qui sont aux alentours dans le sud des
Yvelines une unité mobile axée sur
l'environnement sera basée à Rambouillet
lutte contre les dépôts sauvages les
nuisances sonores ou les feux de forêt
feront partie de ses missions C
gendarmes pourront se déplacer dans
l'ensemble du département elle n'a pas
vocation en première intention à
accueillir le public sa vocation sera
clairement de patrouiller d'aller
constater des infractions et d'accomplir
un travail de police judiciaire sous le
contrôle du procureur de la République
de Versailles et donc c'est un travail
d'enquête avec ses créations le
département des ivelines contre 22
brigades aujourd'hui les effectifs sont
évalués à près de 700 gendarmes et 450
réservistes